[Music]
we met b-boy Joseph in Atlanta GA hi
Joseph
stop the music
[Music]
as it started
[Music]
pretty sure those
[Music]
thank you yeah thank you yeah I had done
yet though Thank You Joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no I'm
sorry
No thank you Jesse cuz you know I ain't
got a formal training or nothin like I
learned on the streets I was very
impaired n't as it turns out Joseph so
thank you for coming you know that my
mama's on drugs and my daddy in jail
it's not not really relevant born in a
coffee can under a bridge that's
terrible Joseph that's that's awful but
it's not going to my sister shot my
brother while my cousin beat my uncle
it's a little bit much Joseph thank you
very much but put myself through school
by renting my body out as a heroin
suitcase alright I see what's going on
Joseph please we do have other dancers
here today who are waiting their turn
very politely no Joseph let her come on
stay
let her Cup no Joseph if I win this
competition I could put a roof over my
house cuz I got a house egg on a roof
for real does Joseph just one little
thing no don't do it
Joseph's allowed Brees don't finish that
sentence in this earring Joseph also in
this is the bridge he'll have trucks go
over it just because the bridge keep it
15-ton hold it put it in your mouth and
get off my stage rate rate at 6:00 Joe
that's a big truck Seth okay Joseph
please and who is this who is this right
here this is my 12 year old daughter who
I raised all by myself without the help
of anybody else in the entire world she
is my inspiration
Joseph it doesn't matter there's nothing
you can do or say that's going to make
us change our minds today
now right there there right there that's
her daughter she blind come on so I
raised them both by myself without
nobody else's help come get your ticket
to Vegas
I'm getting goosey goosey I am
you